>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Please welcome to our stage,
Carla Hayden and David Ferriero.
[ Music ]
[ Clapping ]
>> Carla Hayden: Well --
>> David Ferriero:
How have you been?
>> Carla Hayden: We call
ourselves partners in crime.
>> David Ferriero: We are
though we're not going to talk
about the crime part
of it, right?
[Laughter] We're just going to
talk about the partner part.
>> Carla Hayden: Well, what's
been really interesting
since I've been in the position
of Library [inaudible] is the
fact that people ask me well,
what does the National
Archives do?
You know --
>> David Ferriero:
What do you mean?
What does that mean?
>> Carla Hayden: What
does the archivist do?
You're the Library of Congress.
And then this -- there's a
confusion about the histories
and the roles of each
of the institutions.
And I've learned a lot in that
even about the tank coming
up to reclaim the
Declaration of Independence,
the Bill of Rights,
and was there a third?
>> David Ferriero: We
call it the Constitution.
[ Laughter ]
>> Carla Hayden: That were
held by the Library of Congress
and that type of thing.
So could you --
>> David Ferriero: Well you got
an earlier start than we did.
It wasn't until the 1930s
that the United States got
serious about its record.
And it was Franklin Roosevelt
who was passionate about records
that we actually created the --
he signed the legislation that
created the National Archives.
The charters that Carla
is referring to had been
in the custody of the
State Department and then
at the Library of Congress.
And when the Archives
building was built,
a beautiful tabernacle
was created
for the Declaration
of Independence.
Doors opened in 1935 but the
librarian of Congress refused
to release the Declaration.
[ Laughter ]
And I've held that against
you [laughter] ever since.
>> Carla Hayden:
I wasn't born then
but I knew this was
going to happen.
>> David Ferriero: And it
wasn't until Harry Truman came
into office that he, you know,
kind of laid down the law
with the new librarian of
Congress that they really needed
to deliver that document
where it belonged.
So as Carla describes it, it
was a really military ceremony
with tanks and military people
lining the steps of the --
and she claims she always
describes it as a grab
for the Declaration
[laughter] but it --
>> Carla Hayden:
Tanks literally --
>> David Ferriero: -- was the
only transfer of the document
to its rightful place.
>> Carla Hayden: And
we have photographs.
Photographs --
>> David Ferriero: We do.
>> Carla Hayden:
-- of the people.
The tanks with the
-- what are those?
>> David Ferriero: Howitzers.
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
[Laughter] Right there waiting
and you can imagine the curators
and the librarians thinking
well maybe it's time.
And who was the librarian
of the Congress then?
Do you remember?
>> David Ferriero: Oh I forget.
Someone here must remember.
>> Carla Hayden: Someone here.
Winston Tab is here.
He is my check on all the time.
>> David Ferriero: Oh Winston.
You were here.
What was the --
[ Laughter ]
>> Carla Hayden: But that
was the start of the kind
of clarification of roles and
to really divide up things.
>> David Ferriero: The
Archives was created to collect
and protect and made
available the records
of the United States government.
So anything that was
created by the government.
So the question -- the natural
question is what about the stuff
that was created before 1934
when the legislation was signed?
A lot of it is in our custody.
Some of it is at the
Library of Congress.
Since the materials were stored
in attics and basements all
over town, a lot of it was
lost through the fire and theft
and flood but what we have
now is a dividing line
between everything
the government creates
and that's me, and everything
they don't create which is you.
>> Carla Hayden: And
sometimes I like to --
and there are times when
I'm glad you're you.
[Laughter] I've learned that.
>> David Ferriero: And there are
times when I wish I were you.
[ Laughter ]
>> Carla Hayden: And I've
described it in another way too
that for instance, Truman and
his official records might be
with the Truman Library
and I'd really like to get
into those things too with the
Presidential Libraries and some
of the letters that he
wrote to his family.
So the person is where you might
-- the things that the person,
the diaries, all of the things
like that, the personal part
and the personal life
of an official might be
at the Library of Congress.
And so the papers
of 23 presidents
from George Washington
to Coolidge are
at the Library of Congress.
And we were both in
Starkville, Mississippi.
>> David Ferriero:
Starkville, Mississippi,
where Ulysses S. Grant is still
probably revolving in his grave
through [multiple speakers].
>> Carla Hayden: And
the Abraham Lincoln.
>> David Ferriero: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: Collection.
>> David Ferriero: Ulysses S.
Grant Presidential Library --
>> Carla Hayden:
Library is in Starkville.
>> David Ferriero:
At -- in Mississippi.
Can you believe it?
>> Carla Hayden:
And we were there.
>> David Ferriero: We were.
>> Carla Hayden: And
[multiple speakers].
>> David Ferriero: It
turns out there are more
than 200 Presidential
sites around the country.
People beyond the
Library of Congress
and the National Archives who
have some kind of responsibility
for some aspect of a President's
life and they're all meeting
in Washington in August.
>> Carla Hayden: And
what's interesting
about the Presidential
Libraries,
the Library of Congress has
custody of the actual papers
and documents of Ulysses
S. Grant and what some
of the Presidential Libraries
do is what they will collect
and make copies of things
from different collections
about a President and
put them in [inaudible].
>> David Ferriero:
Those Presidential
cites, that's right.
Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: Place
and that's how the --
some of the Presidential
Libraries have --
been established.
>> David Ferriero: So when
Franklin Roosevelt created the
National Archives,
he also decided
to have a Presidential Library.
So technically his
was the first --
I'm convinced he was
a closet archivist.
He was really passionate
about his papers
and understood the
importance of archives.
Spent a lot of time hiring the
first archivist and spent a lot
of time supporting
that first archivist,
Robert Connor [phonetic], in his
work as he was trying to figure
out where the records
are, and more importantly,
to convince the agency heads
to give up their records
because that wasn't something
that people were
interested in doing.
So Roosevelt created his
own library or Herbert --
whoever decided he wanted
a library at that point
but this was all voluntary.
It was all voluntary up
until 1972 when thanks
to President Nixon
and his thoughts
that he owned his own records
that legislation was passed,
the Presidential Records Act,
which made it government
property.
So 1972 is kind of our marker
for you have to donate.
You have to give your papers
to the National Archive.
>> Carla Hayden: And so the role
really became official then.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: And then
the other departments
and that's another confusion
that happens sometimes.
>> David Ferriero: Well
it's a separate set of laws.
Presidential Records
Act was 1972.
The Federal Records Act was
created much earlier than that.
And that guides all of the
records management activities
for the Executive Branch.
So all of the 275 Executive
Branch Cabinet level
and agencies and departments.
>> Carla Hayden: What
about congressional records
of [multiple speakers] --
>> David Ferriero: We provide
by a gentleman's
agreement way back when,
we provide courtesy
storage for the records
of Congress and service them.
They are the records of
Congress but they aren't
at the Library of Congress.
>> Carla Hayden: And you --
and I want all of the people
watching and listening
to realize that the joy of
working with your colleagues.
Some that you've known.
I've known David his time at
New York Public and all of that,
is that you have this
kind of friendly,
kind of historical
whatever competition.
[Laughter] So when
you talk about your --
>> David Ferriero:
And some grudges.
Still carrying --
>> Carla Hayden: And grudges.
>> David Ferriero:
-- some grudges.
[Laughter]
>> Carla Hayden: So
when you talk about
and I know you've seen that
movie, National Treasure.
>> David Ferriero: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: You
got all the kids.
>> David Ferriero: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: And they're
doing it but the Library
of Congress has that
first printing
that just had John
Hancock on it.
And then they send it out.
>> David Ferriero: It wouldn't
have been that first printing
if those original signors
didn't sign something.
>> Carla Hayden: See.
[ Laughter ]
And --
>> David Ferriero: Which I have.
>> Carla Hayden: And
David Ferriero --
[laughter] right, right, okay.
It's okay.
And the Gettysburg Address, you
know, that he took on the field.
>> David Ferriero: That's right.
>> Carla Hayden: The contents
of Abraham Lincoln's pockets
the night he was assassinated.
>> David Ferriero:
[Inaudible] I know.
>> Carla Hayden: Four locks
of Thomas Jefferson's hair.
[ Laughter ]
Just saying.
[Laughter] You know, so there
is kind of fun to have this kind
of historical back
and forth with people.
Oh those Tony Marks [phonetic].
He's got a few artifacts
too at New York Public.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
The [inaudible] stolen from
the Vatican by Napoleon.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: There are
a few things over there.
So everybody's -- and let's not
even bring up Hamilton, right?
[Laughter] Let's -- okay
let's bring up Hamilton.
[Inaudible] how did
you pull that off?
>> David Ferriero:
We have Hamilton's --
oh it's through the New York
Public Library actually.
Tommy Kale [phonetic]
[laughter] who was the Director
of Hamilton was a
member of the Library
for the Performing Arts
Visiting Committee.
And he and I became good
friends and when we decided
to honor Ron [inaudible]
and Lynn Manuel [phonetic]
it was through Tommy Kale --
>> Carla Hayden: Oh
was that really good.
>> David Ferriero: -- we got
all three of them in house.
Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: Well, we're
not going to name drop.
Okay.
>> David Ferriero: Not at all.
>> Carla Hayden: We're
just going to let that go.
>> David Ferriero: Not at all.
>> Carla Hayden: We're
going to let that go.
>> David Ferriero: But we
do have Hamilton's Oath
of Allegiance signed at Valley
Forge by George Washington.
>> Carla Hayden: And [laughter]
we just digitized the last note
to his wife, Eliza.
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> David Ferriero: Not yet.
[ Laughter ]
>> Carla Hayden:
It's so much fun.
And then you get
Tony on the side --
>> David Ferriero:
We have [inaudible]
to the government outlining
her poverty asking for support
from the federal government.
>> Carla Hayden: And we just
are finishing digitizing all
of her correspondence
of the rest of her life
when she did his -- and made
-- unburnished his reputation.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden:
So we could go on.
>> David Ferriero: What else are
you doing in the digitization?
>> Carla Hayden: We can go on.
>> David Ferriero: Okay.
>> Carla Hayden: You just
name a historical figure.
If they were official,
that's what you have though.
>> David Ferriero: That's right.
So what are you doing in --
what are we doing together
in the digitization?
>> Carla Hayden: Well, we
are doing some cool stuff.
Why don't you tell them
a little bit about that?
>> David Ferriero: We're
working on the Terrific Exhibit
with the BNF tracing the French
role in the American Revolution.
Working with, I think
you guys are involved
in the New York Public Library.
>> Carla Hayden: New York
Public's very involved.
>> David Ferriero: The BNF,
Library of Congress, and the --
>> Carla Hayden: And the
BNF, just in case people --
>> David Ferriero:
And another project
with the British
Library, George --
>> Carla Hayden:
The two Georges.
>> David Ferriero: Two
Georges about the beginnings
of this country, King
George and our King George.
>> Carla Hayden: We're
calling it the two Georges
because it's their
George, George the Third,
and George Washington.
And the cool thing about it
is that they were reading some
of the same books
at the same time.
They had similar interests and
so it'll be a joint exhibit
with the Royal Archives.
>> David Ferriero: That's right.
>> Carla Hayden: Windsor.
We didn't go to the wedding
but [laughter] our research
timing didn't coincide
but the Royal Archives,
Kings College,
and William and Mary here.
So that type of collaboration
happens all the time
and we keep -- and we mentioned
Tony Marks and New York Public
because in terms of a public
library that has a collection
that complements some of the
things that we're involved in.
New York Public is the
library that we work closely
with in different ways.
So the burning question that
people have asked me already
and it came up at a session, one
of the sessions, what do we do
and how do we deal with
technology going forward?
Some of the historical
records now are going to be
in a different format.
>> David Ferriero:
They already are.
>> Carla Hayden: And you've been
really on the forefront of that
with your -- you were
putting a hard stop
on collecting in analog.
>> David Ferriero: I'm sure
you've read in the press
about the President's
Reform Plan
that was just issued last week.
If you go to page 103, you'll
see a two page description
of the National Archives
contribution
to that reform plan.
And what it spells
out is the message
that we've already
delivered to the agencies
that we are no longer accepting
paper at the end of 2022.
They have until 2022 to
get their paper to us.
That they -- that's in their
custody now that is scheduled
to be transferred but after
2022, it's digital only.
So the agencies have already
been prepared for this.
They've already -- many
of them 85% of them
about have been already
digitizing their records.
So we're in pretty
good shape that way
but the most important factor is
that those agencies are
already creating their records
electronically and they
have been for some time.
So this is not, you know, a
great surprise, a great shock.
And just a data point, since
I know there are some people
who are confused about what's
going on with the Obama --
the planning for
the Obama Library.
It turns out that more than 80%
of the Obama records
are born digital.
There is no paper equivalent.
So the plan is with
the agreement
of the Obama Foundation that
we will create the first all
digital Presidential library.
The money would have
been invested
in creating a physical
facility in Chicago is going
to be devoted to
digitization of that 15%
that isn't already digital.
And that's, you know,
a very different model
for Presidential libraries.
It's a very different model
for how we deliver information
and service the Presidential
records
but it's an exciting
opportunity for us
to rethink a whole new
way of communicating,
connecting with our users.
>> Carla Hayden: Are you going
to be borrowing some techniques
from museums and things in
terms of how you display --
>> David Ferriero: The plan is
that the foundation
has already designed
and will build a museum.
And we will loan
to them artifacts
because the Presidential
libraries are a combination
of paper or film, photographs,
and lots of artifacts,
gifts from foreign
heads of state,
gifts from the American
people, more macaroni pictures
than you've ever
seen in your life.
[Laughter]
>> Carla Hayden: The
things from children.
>> David Ferriero: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: Hopefully.
>> David Ferriero: Oh yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
>> David Ferriero: Every one
of the Presidential libraries
has this kind of collection.
So those are the kinds
of things that will end
up in the museum part of the --
>> Carla Hayden: What about
letters from young people?
>> David Ferriero:
That's part of --
those are all digitized now.
>> Carla Hayden:
Oh that's going --
>> David Ferriero:
They're all digitized.
>> Carla Hayden:
to be very cool --
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: --
to see all the letters
and I know that's a big part.
>> David Ferriero: Well
that's important to me
because when I became
the archivist and met
with the Directors of the
Presidential libraries
for the first time that Director
of the Kennedy handed me a copy
of a letter that a kid wrote
to the President asking
for information about
the proposed Peace Corps.
And it's a letter from me.
[ Laughter ]
Two weeks later the
Eisenhower called
to say they had found
two letters from me
to President Eisenhower and when
I visited the LBJ Library they
gave me a copy of the
letter that I sent
to LBJ congratulating him for
signing the Civil Rights Act.
>> Carla Hayden: David,
you've been working
on this for a while.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clapping ]
That is cool.
>> David Ferriero: So
I'm sure you've heard
about our sleepovers and one
of the activities during our
sleepovers is an opportunity
for the kids to write a
letter to the President.
And we deliver those
letters to the President
on the next Monday morning.
And the White House then
supplies us with a letter
that we can send back to
them thanking the kids
for their interests and some
words of encouragement signed
by the President which
is a pretty nice touch.
>> Carla Hayden:
And I must tell you,
there have been wonderful
moments and things
that have been challenging
but one
of the most challenging
has been trying to figure
out as a former children's
library, right?
How I can top this
wonderful thing that you do
with children in the Archives?
They sleepover by the
Constitution, right?
[ Laughter ]
In that wonderful
place, there they are.
It's night and they're spooky
and they're all really
having fun.
And then the next
morning and I've heard
so many people tell me
this, you know the Archivist
of the United States
makes pancakes
for the kids the next day.
[Laughter] So now
I don't worry --
we have Thomas Jefferson's
recipe for macaroni
and cheese [inaudible].
I'm trying to get
David and David --
>> David Ferriero: She has been
trying to horn into this event
since she arrived [inaudible].
>> Carla Hayden: [Laughter]
And this is really true
because I have -- I said okay,
maybe we can make a
progressive weekend.
>> David Ferriero: A
progressive sleepover.
>> Carla Hayden: See he knows.
[Laughter] I've got him -- at
least you're saying it, David.
[Laughter] Right?
Don't you think that'd be neat?
So we have a new gang of
three, you know, in Washington.
They have gangs of four and
five and eight, everything.
So there's a new gang in
town, it's the gang of three.
It's David Skorton, David
Ferriero, and Carla Hayden.
And we, the Smithsonian, the
Archives, and the Library,
and we've actually met
and we talk about this.
And we might have what
if the kids started
out at the Natural
History Museum, right?
With all that stuff and
then [laughter] I think
that would be -- or they slept
there because I think, you know,
that's -- and so we're
trying to figure this out.
And I think evenings
should be with us
with the macaroni and cheese.
>> David Ferriero: I think
Air and Space, I think Air
and Space already
does a sleepover.
>> Carla Hayden: See.
>> David Ferriero: See.
>> Carla Hayden: See we're
working together now.
>> David Ferriero: But you
did the mention the fact
that David Skorton, that's
an important thing --
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
>> David Ferriero: -- thing
that we should talk about.
And that is the close working
relationship that the three
of us had which is unlike --
>> Carla Hayden: Any --
>> David Ferriero: You
know, I've been there
for eight years almost nine
years and this is the first time
that the three institutions
have really gotten serious
about working together.
>> Carla Hayden: And
it's fun because when --
and so I invited the two
Davids over to the Library
of Congress for the luncheon.
And of course, our
curators and librarians put
out the good silver, we call it.
You know, all of
our stuff, right?
And they're in there.
And we knew that this
David was opera buff.
So we had one of our
music librarians bring
out this wonderful -- these
just opera things that --
tell them some of the
stuff because you know.
I don't --
>> David Ferriero: It
was the first printing
of the first liberto
for an opera.
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> David Ferriero:
Which I had never --
I've never even heard of
which was [inaudible].
>> Carla Hayden: He
had never heard of it.
And then David Skorton
is a jazz fanatic.
So we brought out the
Billie Strayhorn things
that we had just gotten and
all the Jelly Roll Morton.
And then the curator was so
good, he knew opera and jazz.
>> David Ferriero:
And could sing it.
>> Carla Hayden: So he was --
>> David Ferriero:
And he sang --
>> Carla Hayden: And he sang.
[Inaudible] Plus we had
the chicken salad thing
and all that.
It was very nice.
And so this curator had a
piece by Jelly Roll Morton
who is known for jazz that
bridge the two types of music
because Jelly Roll Morton
did an operetta or --
>> David Ferriero: That's right.
That's right.
>> Carla Hayden: --
did something and so he
just slid right into that.
Now David Skorton and I
think we can reveal this,
wanted to get the
card of the curator.
>> David Ferriero: Oh yes.
>> Carla Hayden: So there is
some poaching [inaudible].
>> David Ferriero: He was
trying to steal the curator.
>> Carla Hayden: Right there.
>> David Ferriero:
Right in front of her.
>> Carla Hayden: [Laughter]
Right in front of me.
>> David Ferriero: How
long have you been here?
Are you happy here?
>> Carla Hayden: Are you happy?
[ Laughter ]
Yes he's happy.
And I had to talk to the guy --
>> David Ferriero: Yeah,
you told him he was happy.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
I had to talk to
the guy afterwards.
So are you happy?
So that kind of -- but
it's really a lot of fun
when you start joining forces.
>> David Ferriero:
Yeah but the pressure.
See we're doing the next one.
We're doing the next lunch.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm afraid.
>> David Ferriero: And
the pressure is already
on about what are we
going to show you.
>> Carla Hayden: And
that's the really cool stuff
because women suffrage is
coming up and you have a lot
of things and Smithsonian.
We're doing an exhibit.
We even talked about it as you
mentioned Air and Space Museum.
You have for the Wright Brothers
some pretty cool things.
>> David Ferriero: The
Wright Brothers patent.
Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: The patent.
And the Library of Congress
has the actual papers.
>> David Ferriero: That's right.
>> Carla Hayden: David
McCullough did his book
on the Wright Brothers
was really based on that.
And then the Smithsonian
has the plane.
>> David Ferriero: The model.
Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: And
so we're really working
to see what are some of the
things that we have that each
of us can bring together
for special exhibits
to really put things when one is
having an exhibit on something,
put something about it
in our own institution.
>> David Ferriero: That's right.
>> Carla Hayden: And
the Smithsonian we were
very pleased.
We went halvies [phonetic]
to purchase the first photo,
known photo, of Harriet Tubman.
And it's going to be exhibited
in the new -- we digitized it,
took care of it, and it's
going to be on exhibit
at the new Museum of
African American History
in College Town.
>> David Ferriero: That's great.
>> Carla Hayden:
So that type of --
[clapping] And you'll
see more of it.
Now we'll still have
the friendly rivalry.
It's always fun.
And when Tony comes to play
and puts his thing down there
and all of that but just getting
this community of history
and culture seems to be growing.
And we work together for that.
>> David Ferriero: So what
has surprised you about --
>> Carla Hayden: At the
Library of Congress?
>> David Ferriero: About
working in Washington?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh.
[ Laughter ]
And Tony's over here
going don't say anything.
Tony's like [inaudible].
I still live in Baltimore and --
>> David Ferriero:
That says it all.
>> Carla Hayden: -- I commute.
>> David Ferriero:
That says it all.
>> Carla Hayden: No,
no, no, I commute
and it's really interesting
because I've lived in other --
when I lived in Chicago, there's
so many commuters that came in.
People would come into Chicago
from Gary, Indiana, every day.
And so this idea that people
come in from different states,
different places every day
and I'm taking the train now.
And you just see how many
people come in to the city
and then it goes --
it's like elastic.
And I didn't get a
sense of that before.
You know, you go in and you
think no, there are people
who live there and it grows.
And it really expands.
And how many -- and there's
an energy there that's similar
to New York where
you go into New York
and you just feel a
pace and it changes.
And that's why when I go back to
Baltimore it's like, you know,
we have the Baltimore
[inaudible] and it's different.
>> David Ferriero: It's --
>> Carla Hayden: It's --
>> David Ferriero: And there
are a lot of young people
in [inaudible] which
is really --
>> Carla Hayden: And
they all walk fast
and they have [laughter]
two or three devices.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden:
And they're just --
>> David Ferriero:
But they're all smart.
And they're all passionate
about what they're doing and --
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
>> David Ferriero: It's
really rewarding --
>> Carla Hayden: The brain --
>> David Ferriero:
-- to work with them.
>> Carla Hayden: -- power --
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: --
there is something.
And so the Library
of Congress --
oh, you probably already do it.
>> David Ferriero: Probably.
What is it?
Another idea you've
stolen from us?
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
[Laughter] Because we're going
to talk briefly about one
and in the public
citizen archivist
and the citizen historian
because that is really cool.
So we're working on -- here
you have in Washington, D.C.,
literally some of the brightest,
smartest young people
you will ever ever meet.
And they are just -- some look
like they're 12 years old.
[Laughter] And they
are policy --
I mean they're just something.
And so we have tried to think
of how can we get
these young millennials
or they're not even
millennials, some of them.
>> David Ferriero: Right.
>> Carla Hayden: They're --
engaged because they
are so smart.
So they want to do -- so
we've had scavenger hunts
and a little Jeopardy and
some really cool things
to engage them.
We have libation
sometimes and things
like that but they -- yes.
Thomas Jefferson was
a wine connoisseur.
[ Laughter ]
You know, we work it.
To get these young
people engaged in things
because they want
to still learn.
A lot of them are coming from
these colleges and they're right
out of college and they're --
you know still in Georgetown
and they're doing
all this stuff.
So they will sit and listen to
someone talk about something
or author or something.
They will.
And they want to meet people.
One young congressional
staffer said, you know, we're --
you know our salaries
might, you know, we're here.
And so this is like date night.
They -- to go and
do something kind
of just [inaudible]
in the summer.
Free popcorn.
How about that?
[Laughter] Big screen --
>> David Ferriero:
Ooh, free popcorn.
>> Carla Hayden: -- on the lawn.
With the machine.
It's not just --
>> David Ferriero: Oh my
God with a machine too.
>> Carla Hayden:
With the machine.
[Laughter] With the machine free
popcorn and so then they get
to see -- oh I think we might
have you a little bit on that.
>> David Ferriero:
No I don't think so.
>> Carla Hayden: Wait a minute.
Okay. Wait a minute.
>> David Ferriero: Let me
talk about the Young Founders.
>> Carla Hayden:
Not fundraising.
>> David Ferriero: This
is an idea that I took
from New York Public
Library, the Young Lions.
A similar kind of group really
interested in the library.
Been in existence for what?
Twenty-five years or so.
Some fun day an award, fiction
award for a young author.
And so I took that
idea to the New York --
to the National Archives and
we have a group, similar group
that we're working with, the
Young Founders Society trying
to engage them in the life
of the National Archives.
This is a group of folks
who are drawn in all kinds
of different directions.
So getting them to focus has
been the challenge but --
>> Carla Hayden: We
don't have a name yet.
>> David Ferriero: Oh well.
>> Carla Hayden: So
we're working on that.
I like Young Founders
because then you feel --
>> David Ferriero: Well
it's already been taken.
>> Carla Hayden: I know.
I'm saying this is -- but
that's the good thing.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden:
So we are working
on how we can get this
group and it's going
to be really though --
actually it's the same group
of kids -- or young people.
>> David Ferriero: Probably.
Probably.
>> Carla Hayden:
That will be going
to these types of
things and that --
>> David Ferriero: Well, if you
have any literature you want me
to share with my group I'll --
>> Carla Hayden: Well let's talk
about your citizen
archivist because that one --
>> David Ferriero: Sure.
>> Carla Hayden: -- we
just took almost verbatim
and made it citizen historian
because of the transcription
and things.
>> David Ferriero: So when I was
hired in 2009 by President Obama
and on his first day in
office, he told his senior staff
that the government doesn't
have all the answers and we need
to figure out ways to
engage the American public
in solving some of
those problems.
And I took that to heart and
worked with the staff to think
about ways that we could
engage the American public
in the work that we do.
And the result of
that was the creation
of the citizen archivist
dashboard which has a number
of activities that you
can help us do our work.
Tagging photographs.
Identifying this is
become fairly standard now,
identifying people in
places in photographs.
But I think the centerpiece,
the thing I'm most excited
about is the transcription
project that we have going
on where we've loaded
thousands of records.
Kids aren't being
taught [inaudible].
>> Carla Hayden: Cursive.
>> David Ferriero:
[Inaudible] or -- in schools.
>> Carla Hayden:
Definitely not [inaudible].
>> David Ferriero:
[Laughter] And I have billions
of records in cursive.
So we're, you know,
disenfranchising an
entire generation
and future generations because
they can read this stuff.
So we have people all over
the country and actually all
over the world who are
helping us transcribe
in this citizen archivist
dashboard activity.
So that's a way that we're
trying to engage the public
in helping do our work.
>> Carla Hayden: And we just put
citizen historian and took it
because the model is so great.
And there is the same need
at the Library of Congress.
>> David Ferriero: That's right.
>> Carla Hayden: Susan
B. Anthony's papers.
All these people.
Frederick Douglas.
Some of the things
that are in cursive
that literally young people
and because of the writing,
sometimes other people
can't read these documents.
So the Library of Congress is
launching citizen historian
and we even reference
and say it started
with the National
Archives, citizen archivist
because we want people
that are doing one to think
about doing the other too.
>> David Ferriero: Well and
we're also working together
on are history hub
site where we're --
our reference folks are
sharing, collaborating --
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> David Ferriero: -- and
providing reference service
to anyone who has a
particular reference question.
We're fielding and
sharing information
from our own collections
to solve the research needs
of the people who are
using history hub.
So that's another -- and
we're bringing the Smithsonian
on board with that also.
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> David Ferriero: And I
noticed that your folks were
at the National Archives
last week
for an editathon [phonetic],
a Wikipedia editathon.
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
>> David Ferriero: So we're
working together on Wikipedia.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah,
working together.
And I also want to share
what I know we've talked
about a little bit.
The concern about
history going forward
and records being created
digitally and how we deal
with storage issues,
security, technology,
keeping up in the future, and
there's real concern at time.
That future historians
how will get these items
as history's being made
in a different format.
>> David Ferriero:
It's the one thing --
of all the things that keep me
up at night, this is the one --
>> Carla Hayden: That's the one.
>> David Ferriero: --
that keeps me up at night.
Yeah. It's ensuring that, you
know, our mandate is to ensure
that people have access to
the records in perpetuity
and you know, we're barely
able to guarantee that in paper
but being able to guarantee
that in the electronic
environment is our
biggest challenge.
>> Carla Hayden: Is --
>> David Ferriero: And I
always have in the back
of my head the work
that Nicholson Baker did
in a book entitled Double Fold.
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
>> David Ferriero:
Where he chastised us
for microfilming all of those
early American newspapers
and throwing out the originals.
And leaving us in a
situation where here
in the United States
we did not have copies
of our own newspapers.
>> Carla Hayden: That's right.
>> David Ferriero: Because
the microfilm was --
and the microfilm is so poorly
created and disintegrated
in some cases but
there was no --
in lots of reels
no quality control.
So the images weren't perfect
and the worst thing was
that many of the -- The New York
Herald was the first, I believe,
newspaper to introduce color
into the comics on
Sunday editions.
And the newspaper
microfilm is black and white.
So we lost the whole sense of
our history in a flawed project.
>> Carla Hayden: And that --
>> David Ferriero: But I am
happy to report Nicholson Baker,
the month that the
book came out,
Nicholson Baker's book came
out, the librarian community,
of course, have circled
the wagons
and Nicholson is our enemy.
[Laughter] And I was opening
a new storage facility
at Duke University and
I needed a speaker.
And I invited Nick to come
and be our speaker to open
because here is this
warehouse of paper.
Isn't this wonderful, Nick?
And we had dinner --
Nick had raised the money
from his borrowing
from in-laws to buy
from the British Library the
only paper copies that existed.
The British Library
was [inaudible] them.
And Nick bought them and setup
a warehouse in New Hampshire.
He became a newspaper librarian
and was providing photographs
and things, scanned images
from this collection.
So and I invited Nick
to be our speaker.
He came. We had dinner.
And I told him when you get
tired of newspaper librarian,
this wonderful new facility
that you just dedicated would
be a great place to house them.
And so those newspapers
are at Duke University now.
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> David Ferriero: Thank God.
So I always have that in
my mind when I'm thinking
about what we're dealing
with with this electronic
information.
So that we don't get
into the position
where we've lost everything
because of the security
things --
>> Carla Hayden: Sure.
>> David Ferriero:
Technology, all kinds of issues.
>> Carla Hayden: And
the security thing
that becomes even more of an
issue with the technology.
The Library of Congress, for
instance, has storage modules
and they are modules
but think Amazon
and what those warehouses look
like in Fort Meade,
military base.
[Inaudible] that.
The electronic environment
in terms of security
and making those transitions
as technology progresses.
So there's that fiscal part
that's a major challenge too.
>> David Ferriero: Exactly
and we're doing a lot of work
with the industry to educate
them about what the needs are
around tools that -- for, in
my case, the agencies need
to create and maintain
their records.
The situation in the federal
government is very much the
situation that I remember
from the university settings
where every agency -- I mean
every faculty was able to go off
and build their own system or
buy something off the shelf.
And there was no
interoperability.
There was no enterprise
approach to technology
and that is clearly
the description
of the federal government
that --
>> Carla Hayden: So
each department --
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: --
has its own way --
>> David Ferriero: Right.
>> Carla Hayden: -- of
sealing [inaudible].
>> David Ferriero: So the state
of information technology
infrastructure is not
where it should be and that's
another issue that's outlined
in the reform plan.
Another point that is
in support of the work
that we're trying to do.
>> Carla Hayden: What about
the resources to keep up?
>> David Ferriero:
Well that's -- yeah.
How's your budget?
>> Carla Hayden: Ah.
[Laughter] Well the technology,
it actually been very supported
in terms of the technology
effort and bringing the Library
of Congress to be a
modern and very efficient.
And that's been very heartening
coming in and seeing that
and having that kind of support.
And you know, that you
have to maintain it
and also the staffing
that you need to have
that digital strategy
that's going to be able
to look forward and keep going.
So we just hired a digital
strategy manager and are going
to do more with that
because we have to.
We have to look at and also
look back at the same time.
>> David Ferriero: Exactly.
>> Carla Hayden: So it's a fun
time in a lot of ways because --
>> David Ferriero: You should --
we should actually put that --
>> Carla Hayden: -- we're
getting a lot of people
from the technology sector that
are coming into the library
to work and to help us to try
to solve some of these things.
And that's brought a --
some energy and some
cross fertilization.
That's been real
exciting for us.
>> David Ferriero: That's
something we should put
on our agenda for the
three of us when we --
>> Carla Hayden: The technology.
And we even had and I
referred back to Tony.
One of his -- he hired someone
from Great Britain
to come over --
>> David Ferriero: BBC.
>> Carla Hayden: The BBC.
That is a technology digital
guru and we had him come
to the Library of Congress
and talk to our staff
about what New York
Public is doing.
They're -- we're a little
jealous of some of the stuff
but they're doing a
lot of cool things.
And we had him come.
So just this cross fertilization
between institutions,
between types of libraries,
archives, has been, I think,
helpful for us to share and
say hey we have common problems
and what could we do together.
Now the -- we have the
young professionals.
We have the children.
Are you working on
things for seniors?
>> David Ferriero:
Things for seniors.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh good.
[ Laughter ]
>> David Ferriero: Yeah we're
planning a sleepover for --
>> Carla Hayden: No --
[ Laughter ]
[ Clapping ]
Well we have a wonderful
partnership
with AARP, I must say.
They've supported the Book
Festival and some other things.
And --
>> David Ferriero: We have a
lot of support from them also.
>> Carla Hayden: I know you do
but what can we do
to engage seniors?
And as I'm mature, that becomes
a particular interest as well.
>> David Ferriero: We do have --
it's been interesting to watch
this transcription project
because there are a number
of senior centers
and nursing homes.
There's a nursing home in Lynn,
Massachusetts who has adopted us
and is doing transcriptions.
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
>> David Ferriero: Which
I think is wonderful.
>> Carla Hayden: And see that's
in terms of retired professors
and people that want
to keep engaged.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: And because
you can do it remotely
that with limited mobility
with a lot of seniors.
This is a way that they can
keep involved and keep that
but we're going to have -- I
won't even -- well I can --
>> David Ferriero:
What are you doing?
>> Carla Hayden:
About cooking to --
>> David Ferriero:
Macaroni and cheese.
>> Carla Hayden: Stay tuned.
>> David Ferriero: Probably.
The Library of Congress has one
of the world's largest
collections
of historical cookbooks.
So imagine what programming
you could do with that.
>> David Ferriero: Amazing.
>> Carla Hayden: Not
going to say anything
because he'll steal it because
he probably has the patent
to whatever the mixer [laughter]
or something like that.
You do. You do.
>> David Ferriero: Well before
your time we had a blockbuster
exhibit called What's
Cooking Uncle Sam
about the government's role in
food which told the story --
a horrible story about testing
preservatives and the changes
of the food groups over time.
Did you know butter
used to be a food group?
Butter.
>> Carla Hayden: I
still think it is.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah I'm for that.
Yeah. Well the -- and I have
to talk about your shop.
You just renovated and you
have a new education center
and your shop is to die for.
>> David Ferriero: Yeah, I know.
I heard you were trying
to steal my shop manager.
>> Carla Hayden: I was scouting.
You know? We're renovating
our shop.
We're renovating our shop.
I had to do a field trip and
I did talk to the nice lady.
She seems moderately happy.
[ Laughter ]
I mean she did your shop.
She's ready for a new challenge.
>> David Ferriero: We stole her.
You know we stole
her from the zoo.
[ Laughter ]
>> Carla Hayden: I'm not
saying a word with that one.
I'm letting that go.
>> David Ferriero: In her first
year, she introduced socks
into the repertoire
and $100,000 worth
of socks in the first year.
>> Carla Hayden: That's right.
>> David Ferriero: Your shop --
the really cool thing about
the Archives and the shop is
that when you're in a
section and they have sections
that are just wonderful
about subjects and eras,
the World War II,
and all of this.
There are the terminals
right there that connect you
to the collections and
what else you can do.
So right when you're making
that decision about purchasing,
you also are being tied
to the Archives and that.
And that's what really makes it
not just a retail experience.
Those are great but the
tie in to the content
of the Archives is
what really got it.
>> David Ferriero: So
then if you've never been
to the National Archives,
there are two entrances.
One on Pennsylvania Avenue and
one on Constitution Avenue.
The Constitution side is
if you want to come in
and see the charters
and the exhibits
and the museum side
of the house.
And the other side
is for research.
You come in that door to use
the collection to do research.
And I've been -- since I
got there trying to figure
out ways to break that wall.
Break a hole through that wall
so that there's more interaction
on both sides so that you get
a taste on the museum side
about what's possible.
Genealogists -- genealogy
is our biggest market.
Most -- [cheering] --
genealogists than anything else.
Genealogists then Veterans and
then everything else after that
but some way to use
the experience --
immediate experience
from the museum
on the other side
in the research.
On the research side to
get people more interested
and excited about
not just genealogy
but our records in general.
Learning more about
our history and more --
most important, learning
about civics
and how the government works.
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
>> David Ferriero: And what the
three branches of government are
and what their responsibilities
are as American citizens.
That's what --
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> David Ferriero: --
I'm trying to figure out.
>> Carla Hayden:
[Clapping] Well we all are.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.